- [Voiceover] Hello grammarians.
Today, I wanna talk about
ending sentences with prepositions,
and I wanna tell you, straight
up, it is totally okay.
Like, it is perfectly
grammatically correct and sensible
and fine to end sentences
with prepositions in English.
And if you don't know
what I mean, that's fine.
Let me throw out some examples.
"It's a crazy world we
live in," for example,
is a sentence that ends in
"in," which is a preposition.
And for years, for hundreds of years,
there have been people,
language authorities
that have been telling you it's not okay
to end a sentence with a preposition.
Let me tell you, by
the power vested in me,
it is totally okay.
This is one of those
language superstitions
that will not die.
Taking away the terminal preposition
takes away sentences like,
"That's not behavior I'll put up with."
And, in fact, some of you have maybe heard
the statement that is
supposedly attributed
to Winston Churchill where he says,
"That is something with
which up I will not put,"
which kinda emphasizes how
clunky that is, you know?
If that's supposed to
be formal high language,
it sounds really inarticulate.
Not a fan.
This is ultimately a question
not of grammar but of style
because there's nothing about
"It's a crazy world we live
in," that doesn't make sense
that doesn't function as a sentence.
Indeed, there's nothing
grammatically incorrect
with, "This is behavior with
which up I will not put,"
it's just needlessly verbose
and twisting back on itself
for the sake of avoiding something
that doesn't need to be avoided.
And we can trace all of
this back to Robert Lowth,
a man who was the Bishop of London
during part of the 18th century,
and he wrote about terminal prepositions
in his 1762 "Short Introduction
to English Grammar,"
which reads in part, "This is an idiom
"which our language is
strongly inclined to;
"it prevails in common conversation
"and suits very well with the
familiar style in writing;
"but the placing of the preposition
"before the relative is more graceful,
"and agrees much better with
the solemn and elevated style."
But, Bishop Lowth, may
I direct your attention
to this part of your statement?
"This is an idiom which our language
"is strongly inclined to."
Even when Bishop Lowth
is using what he calls
this solemn and elevated style,
he himself can not avoid ending a clause,
boom, with a preposition.
Game, set, match, sir.
The question is, why did Lowth
have such a bee in his bonnet
about prepositions at
the end of sentences?
And the answer can be found in Latin.
Follow me over to the next screen.
Here is the deal with Latin.
In Latin, prepositions have
a very particular function,
similar to how they work in English.
But let's break apart what
the word preposition is.
In Latin, the word "preposition"
comes from "prae positio,"
which means "placed before,"
right here, placed before,
because here's something cool about Latin:
Latin's word order rules are different
than English's word order rules.
I'll explain.
You know, in English,
we have this expression,
"To put the cart before the horse,"
which means to embark on a project
before you're really ready.
And this is a very ancient
expression, in fact,
one that can be attested in Latin like so.
"Ante equum carrum ponere," right?
Okay, so this is, "Before
the horse, the cart to put."
Here's the thing about
prepositions in Latin
is that in Latin, this, "ante," before,
always has to be positioned
before the word it's attached
to, so before the horse.
But in Latin, you can rearrange
this sentence any way you like.
So, you could say, "Carrum
ponere ante equum."
And just because of the way Latin works,
because of its case endings
and because of this
prepositional relationship,
we can always tell, no matter
what order the words are in,
how the sentence parts
relate to one another.
Or we could also switch it around:
"Ponere carrum ante equum," right?
It could in any order, as
long as ante was before equum.
Now, admittedly, in English,
if you wanted to end this
with a preposition, it would
still sound pretty awkward,
like, "The cart is the thing
that the horse is before,"
but it is still grammatical.
If you move this thing, if
you move "ante" out of order,
there's no way to tell what's
going on in this sentence.
Latin, during the time that
Lowth was Bishop of London,
was the language of scholarship, right?
It was this language that enabled people
all over the European continent
to communicate with each other
in a common language of knowledge.
It was the language of
religion and philosophy.
And all of that added up
to make Latin really cool,
and also very powerful.
And because of the history
of the English language,
which basically entails people in boats
coming over the North Sea
to beat the tar out of
Celts and Anglo-Saxons
and leave Latin- or Norse-
or French-shaped dents in their language,
English has this kind of
uncomfortable relationship with Latin.
English scholars kinda had
an inferiority complex.
And so, during the 17th and 18th century,
you really see this move
towards Latinizing English,
trying to make English grammar
behave more like Latin grammar.
But English comes from a
different language heritage;
it's a Germanic language.
And that doesn't mean it's
better or worse than Latin,
it just means it's different,
and it behaves differently.
We shouldn't try to treat English
as though it were anything
other than English.
So, if anyone ever tells you
that you can't end a
sentence with a preposition,
send them this page.
Or if you prefer, you know
where to send them to,
which is here on Khan Academy,
where you can learn anything.
David out.